Have you ever bought something nice for
your apartment or your room,
brought it home,
put it in place,
and had the thought,
Jesus,
my apartment is a piece of shit,
or maybe you bought a new shirt and
suddenly you're grabbing for it all the
time,
waiting for that day in the rotation
when you can wear it again,
tired of everything you already own.
The name for this social consumer's
phenomenon is called the [inaudible]
effect,
and it works on two principles.
First step,
all the products purchased by a consumer
aim to be cohesive with that consumer's
identity with all the products that they
already owned.
Second,
that the introduction of a new product,
which is desirable button anyway,
deviant from the existing cohesion,
can trigger a process of spiraling
consumption.
In other words,
as much as we decry the dangers of a
materialist society,
the things we own comprise a significant
part of who we are.
Our identities are tied up in our
clothes and our gadgets and the way of
our furniture more than anything else.
We try to find a unity in our
possessions and by extension,
try to convince ourselves that our
identity itself is uniform.
The effect was first identified by its
namesake.
French philosopher Denny Dita wrote in
an essay called regrets on potting with
my own dressing gown.
I don't know why I did an English accent
there.
He's French in the sad truth is given a
brand new scarlet dressing gown to
replace his worn out one,
but soon laments that the luxury of his
new item shames all his other
possessions,
so he goes on a rampage and replaces
everything he owns with beautiful new
things.
Eventually putting himself in serious
debt.
I was the absolute master of my old
robe.
He says,
I have become the slave of my new one.
The effect is at the core of the
materialist ethos,
prodded by that familiar yearning of
keeping up with the Joneses to fit in or
even outclass those around us and in the
media.
We are not capable of stopping at simply
upgrading or updating one corner of what
we own.
We grabbed fee virtually at a better
kind of unity even at the expense of our
financial wellbeing.
This poses a problem for companies that
produce goods.
It's why stuff usually comes in sets and
those sets usually at a discount.
It's why Ikea showcases full rooms in
there.
Disney Disneyland,
like tour of the kinds of people you can
be.
Can we be blamed for this materialist
craving in us?
Well,
the answer is definitely yes,
but a soft yes,
a soft yes for we who are pampered rats
within the capitalist construct,
modern men and women laboring as rust.
Cole says an illusion of having a
cohesive uniform identity.
It seems to us might be some solve
against the chaotic truth.
That reality is as fractious and self
constructed as we are one day we'll have
to strike out against this insane
consumerism.
Until then,
the Ikea spring living room set is as
good as crack.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
The [inaudible] effect is a really
interesting social phenomenon tied in
with a lot of other things.
You can read more about it in the links
that I'll put in the description below.
All companies that make goods and
services deal with this problem.
The environmentalist movement,
for example,
is no exception.
Green,
good producers and cis not on buying
their stuff,
but on replacing the harmful things that
you already follow me on twitter.
I love to tweet and try to make people
think or laugh or smile or whatever.
I just think it's an awesome platform.
Um,
and uh,
I'm going to put this video on reddit
and hopefully it gets some traction.
I'll put the link there when I do an
upload it.
If you enjoyed this video read,
it's been awesome in spreading the stuff
that I make and I'll see you next week.